good afternoon today we transmit the
report of the work of three committees
the Intelligence Committee the oversight
committee as well as the Foreign Affairs
Committee into the president's
misconduct with respect to Ukraine and
at the outset I want to just thank the
incredible members of all three
committees as well as our amazing staff
that did long hours of work through
depositions open hearings and compiling
all of the evidence into today's report
it was an enormous task and I want to
begin by acknowledging the great work of
the great and late colleague of mine
Elijah Cummings we continue to be
inspired by his legacy and guided by
thoughts of his integrity and the great
moral clarity that he always showed in
his work I also want to thank my
colleagues to chairman Engel
Sherwin woman Maloney for their
tremendous work as well this report
chronicles the scheme by the president's
tates to coerce an ally Ukraine that is
at war with an adversary Russia into
doing the pleasant the president's
political dirty work it involves a
scheme in which Donald Trump withheld
official acts a White House meeting as
well as hundreds of millions of dollars
of needed military assistance in order
to compel that power to deliver two
investigations that he believed would
assist his re-election campaign and I
want to underscore first of all just how
important that White House meeting was
to Ukraine Ukraine has a new reformer as
its president president szalinski a
meeting with the most important patron
of Ukraine the president United States
in the Oval Office carries enormous
significance both to the people of
Ukraine but as equally important
to Russia that the United States has
Ukraine's back in its conflict with a
nation which invaded its territory the
military assistance is also absolutely
essential as president Solinsky goes
into negotiations with Vladimir Putin
the fact that the United States is
providing substantial military
assistance approved on a bipartisan
basis by Congress is enormous ly
important the withholding of that aid
even for a period of time
sends a disastrous message to friend and
foe alike that the United States does
not have the back of its ally so these
were things that Ukraine desperately
wanted and needed at the same time there
was something president Trump
desperately wanted and believed that he
needed and that was an investigation
that would damage the rival that he
feared apparently the most Joe Biden as
well as they investigation into a
debunked conspiracy theory that it was
Ukraine not Russia that interfered in
our last election now that conspiracy
theory which is often summarized or
characterized by the term CrowdStrike
that conspiracy theory is a Russian
narrative that is a conspiracy theory
put out promulgated by Vladimir Putin to
deflect attention away from Russia's
interference in our own election and to
try to drive a wedge between the United
States and the nation of Ukraine so
that's what the president wanted these
two sham investigations one into Joe
Biden also debunked and discredited that
that sham investigative theory but also
into this idea that Ukraine interfered
in our election not Russia and he was
willing to sacrifice the national
security of the United States by
withholding military aid and diplomatic
recognition of the form of that Light
House meeting in order to get what he
wanted that scheme however was
discovered because among other things a
courageous person stepped forward and
blew the whistle but also because
Congress announced that it would
investigate the matter once we began our
investigation and once it became clear
to the
and to the White House that this was
going to become public this scheme was
going to become public only then did the
president on States release the military
aide and ask for that White House
meeting that Ukraine so desperately
sought that is still not happened to
this day now what does this mean for
Americans why should they care about
what the President did visa vie Ukraine
why should they care indeed about
Ukraine first of all this is not about
Ukraine this is about our democracy this
is about our national security this is
about whether the American people have a
right to expect that the president I
states is going to act in their
interests with their security of mind
and not for some illicit personal or
political reason so Americans should
care deeply about whether the president
ID States is betraying their trust in
him betraying that oath that he took to
the Constitution to protect our country
and defend its institutions so we should
care about this we must care about this
and if we don't care about this we can
darn well be assured the president will
be back at it doing this all over again
because indeed he already has first
there was the invitation to Russia to
interfere in our last election hey
Russia if you're listening hack
Hillary's emails and indeed later that
day they tried to do exactly that but
then there was the use of this official
power to compel another country Ukraine
to interfere in the 2020 election and
even after even after our investigation
began even after the impeachment inquiry
began there was president Donald Trump
out on the White House lawn once again
making it abundantly clear that he
wanted Ukraine to investigate the
Biden's and what's more he wanted other
countries to interfere in our election
as well and that China should also
investigate the Biden's this is the
result of a president who believes that
he is beyond indictment beyond
impeachment beyond any form of
accountability and indeed above the law
and that is a very dangerous thing for
this kind
three to have an unethical president who
believes they're above the law the
question now is what does Congress do
about this one of the other very
important elements of our report today
which goes beyond the president's
misconduct with Ukraine goes to the
president's obstruction of the Congress
of a co-equal branch of government and I
want to underscore also the seriousness
of this misconduct because the president
informed every department for which we
sought records the State Department the
office of management budget which has
the records about the withholding of the
aid the Defense Department his own White
House personnel to refused to turn over
a single document and answer to
congressional subpoenas the president
instructed witnesses not to appear the
president used his office and his bully
pulpit to try to intimidate witnesses if
the Congress allows a present to so
fully and blanketly obstructed the work
of Congress even involving an
impeachment investigation into the
president's own misconduct then we are
begging for more of the same we are
signaling to any future president they
can gauge in it whatever corruption
malfeasance or negligence and they are
beyond accountability and to my GOP
colleagues they need to consider that
when we have a Democratic president are
they willing to say in answer to their
oversight that a president may simply
refuse because if they are and if we do
it will mean that the balance of power
between our branches of government will
be fundamentally altered and altered for
the worse it will mean that future
corruption malfeasance and incompetence
will be far more likely than it is today
the facts here are really not seriously
contested indeed the testimony of the
witnesses was remarkably consistent and
you might be forgiven having watched the
hearings and watch the reaction of the
member
of the two parties to the testimonies
witnesses if you thought that there were
two different hearings going on at the
same time this points out another danger
that the founding fathers were all too
aware of and that is the danger of
accept excessive factionalism that is
that a political party may become so
wedded to a present of their own party
that they're unwilling to do their
constitutional duty but I firmly believe
that if one party relinquishes its
responsibilities to the Constitution
into their oath it does not relieve us
of our obligation to the same and I hope
that every member of the House and the
Senate whether these proceedings go
forward in the house or they don't we'll
keep in mind their duty is to the
Constitution not to the person of the
president that ought to be our guiding
principle finally I think what's
presented to us here is really so aptly
summed up in what the president's own
chief of staff had to say when he
informed the country that yes indeed
they had withheld military aid to get
this political investigation he told us
to get over it
to get over it that is what the
president does we should just get over
it this is essentially what he was
saying that we need to just get used to
the idea of a corrupt president and get
over it and so we will have to decide
given that the evidence of this
misconduct is so clear and uncontested
are we prepared to just get over it are
we prepared to say that henceforth we
must expect from this president and
those who follow that there will be a
certain amount of corruption in which
the national security the country will
be compromised in which the oath of the
office will mean that much less in which
the belief in the rule of law in the
United States will be that much
les is that what we're simply to get
over or get used to well I for one don't
think we should get over this I don't
think we should get used to this I don't
think that's what the founders of this
country had in mind indeed I think that
when they prescribed a remedy this kind
of conduct by a president on States
putting his own personal political
interests above the interest of the
American people was exactly why they
prescribed a remedy as extraordinary as
the remedy of impeachment and so we have
a very difficult decision ahead of us to
make and I have every confidence that
the Judiciary Committee in consultation
with the entire caucus and our
leadership will not only receive this
report as well as the reports of others
and make a proper determination about
whether articles of impeachment are
warranted with that I'm happy to respond
your questions well I can't go into
specifics of you know dates in which we
obtain certain evidence or indeed
whether we obtained communications from
one or multiple parties but certainly
the phone records show that there was
considerable coordination among the
parties including the White House
coordination in the smear campaign
against ambassador Jovanovic which
cleared the way for the three amigos to
take over a significant part of Ukraine
policy coordination in the execution of
that policy and that that this was
indeed a continuum that began even prior
to the recall of the ambassador now your
question gets to a very important point
which is there is more investigative
work to be done
one of the issues that we are looking
into is did this scheme begin far
earlier than we first understood was the
scheme in fact put in place to try to
pressure the last president of Ukraine
poroshenko and his corrupt
prosecutor general lute Senko into
conducting these same investigations and
was that plan put into turmoil and chaos
when this new reformer szalinski surged
in the polling and ultimately won that
presidency that is something we continue
to investigate and that is something
that these phone records also shed light
on but even as we believe that we cannot
wait because the president's efforts to
secure intervention the next election
persist we continue our investigation
and and we will I'm gonna reserve any
kind of a public judgement on that until
I have a chance to consult with my
colleagues with our leadership and I
think this really needs to be a decision
that we all make as a body so I'm going
to continue to reserve judgment but I
can tell I am gravely concerned that if
we merely accept this that we invite not
only further corruption of our elections
by this president but we also invite it
of the next president so I am keenly
aware of the significance of the
precedent we set in whatever direction
we move and I'm also very strongly
guided by the fact that one of the
seminal moments in this scheme took
place the day after Bob Muller testified
the day after Donald Trump thought that
the last investigation was over he began
the next significant step in a new
course of misconduct yes
well I you know I would say a couple
things first of all as I mentioned
you'll we continue investigate whether
this scheme began earlier than expected
whether this scheme also involved the
last president of Ukraine but look we
have provided overwhelming evidence in
this report of a scheme to pressure the
current president of Ukraine to conduct
these political investigations will it
move others if we're able to show that
this was not the first time this was the
second time I think what we have
produced in in remarkable short order is
so overwhelming that it ought to be
presented to the Judiciary Committee now
without any further delay if we do
uncover additional evidence and and we
do learn more every day we will feel
free to file supplemental reports to the
Judiciary Committee but there is I think
rave risk to the country with waiting
until we have every last fact when we
already know enough about the
president's misconduct to make a
responsible judgment about whether we
think that's compatible with the office
of the presidency yes no they don't at
least that I can identify at this moment
I think the phone records are remarkably
consistent with the coordination of a
lot of this scheme now we obviously
don't have complete phone records and
some of the phone records are deeply
suggestive of who the parties were
talking to particularly in the White
House or the Office of Management budget
but because of the president's effort to
stonewall investigation including not
turn over their own phone records not
only to us but to witnesses like sunland
who asked for them we don't have all the
answers but we do know this without any
doubt and that is the president the
United States solicited foreign
interference in our election and used
the power of his office
the power to convene a meeting in the
Oval Office the power to provide her
with hold hundreds and millions of
dollars of aid to an ally at war to get
his political dirty work done the only
question is how much more how more
extensive was the scheme how many others
may have been involved what was the full
knowledge of participation of other
parties and while we intend to get the
answers to those questions and let the
American people know the full facts we
do not intend to delay when the
integrity of the next election is still
at risk
the rules adopted by the Judiciary
Committee provide that our staff council
will present the report to the committee
so that's what we expect will take place
in terms of the ranking member it won't
surprise you Alma to reserve comment it
is I think deeply concerning that at a
time when the president knighted States
was using the power of his office to dig
up dirt on a political rival that there
may be evidence that there were members
of Congress complicit in that activity
now there's a lot more to learn about
that and I don't want to state that that
is an unequivocal fact but the
allegations are deeply concerning our
focus is on the president's conduct
first and foremost it may be the role of
others to evaluate the conduct of
members of Congress thank you very much